hey  steven spielberg  it's me academy award-winning actor  nick cage and  i  want to audition  for lincoln  slavery man that is not cool four score  and seven years ago man  our forefathers brought forth freaking  america  my fellow americans i have invented the  five dollar bill  can i keep this i just invested in a  miniature horse farm  shall we stop this bleeding seriously  the walls are bleeding don't you see it  how do we  stop that  oh  [ __ ]  not the bees no  not the bees  you know i could also play mary todd  uh  abe honey  don't  go to the theater  tonight  you know i have a  premonition  i see snakes  possum blood  and uh i just  i'm really horny too  a b c d e f g h i j k l m n o p q r s t  u v w x y z  huh  oh man  i've been shot in the head  suck it  well hey stevo thanks for watching i  could really use the work i have a  couple of late payments on my island so